Any deck I find myself playing for a
long enough period of time generally
earns itself its own dedicated video, a
deck tech. That happened 21 months after
I built Shroom Slide, seven months after
I built Glissa Incubators, four months
after I built my Malcolm Time Sieve
deck, one month after building my Radha
deck, and also one month after putting
together an updated version of my Maga
deck. In part, this is for entirely
ordinary YouTuber reasons. I need to
figure out two things a month to talk
about, and a deck I like to play makes
for an easy thing make one of those two.
However, this is also because my
favorite decks tend to be evocative,
meticulously crafted to scratch a very
specific itch, and for this reason they
also often serve as good lenses through
which to analyze a specific play style
or a specific motivation when building a
deck. Relevant to this discussion is the
fact that my decks tend to revolve
around a specific vibe I find appealing,
whether that be forcing the table into a
cutthroat low-resource game, unstoppably
[snorts] accumulating resources for
myself, or navigating a strategic
minefield to a narrow control victory.
Because my decks feature specific play
patterns I find personally satisfying, I
like to think they can be helpful
documents of how I crafted an enjoyable
experience for myself, and possible
inspiration for how others can do the
same. It's with all this in mind that we
need to talk about the elephant in the
room, my Liesa deck. I first built this
deck in April 2023, 35 months ago, and
it has stayed among my five to six core
decks ever since. I've even talked about
it in a handful of different videos
because it has accomplished some
interesting things and offered some
intriguing lessons.
What it hasn't done, though, is ever be
quite satisfying enough to make a whole
video about. It's never scratched the
itch I wanted to scratch well enough to
be worth talking about.
This is kind of funny to me because I've
known precisely what itch I wanted to
scratch basically the whole time. I
wanted to make my opponents think about
their life total a lot. I said precisely
this in a Discord message I sent to a
friend in June of 2023, and I also laid
out this thought process in a video
about aggro in October of that year. An
aggressive game plan can mean the
ability to knock opponents out of the
game early, but even before that
happens, the first 20 to 30 damage dealt
to an opponent already influences the
way they play the game. It makes them
play more conservatively, attack less
confidently, and feel a lot less
confident about the life paid tools that
are such a common feature in Commander.
And, relevantly here, a low life total
especially does that if I can keep
around a creature that drains opponents
whenever they cast spells.
So, I was already in a great starting
position with my command zone being a
command tax dodger who drains anybody
who casts spells. So, how exactly did I
manage to fail at adequately scratching
this itch for multiple years?
Well, it's been a complex road of
confused intentions and muddy goals
with multiple rounds of heavy reworks
and This is where the command zone comes
into play for this particular deck. My
hate bears can whittle down life totals
a bit and generally gum up the works of
the game, and then Liesa is my follow-up
that can really start to cut down life
totals in this slowed environment. This
theory largely worked out in reality. I
had a suite of 16 hate bears alongside
modest counts of protection, ramp, draw,
and removal, as well as some extra tools
to help Liesa in cutting down opposing
life totals. Still, I found myself
having some issues with that original
deck. In retrospect, the biggest one is
that it felt more stacks than it did
Liesa.
However, at the time I was only
distantly aware of this, and more
focused on another undeniably present
problem. The deck didn't have all that
much draw, which just kind of made it
boring to play. My opponents couldn't do
much, but neither could I.
So, in early 2024, I did a round of
tweaks on the deck to get more value
generation in there and generally to
make it more interesting to play. And I
added a lot of value generation, three
more general purpose options and five
cards that contain a particular mechanic
I wanted to play around with, the
initiative. The initiative is a mechanic
that causes a player to travel through
the Undercity, which triggers an effect
in a room whenever a player takes the
initiative, whenever they start their
turn with the initiative, or whenever
they take back the initiative from an
opponent who stole it by attacking them.
It's like monarch, but needlessly
complicated for entirely aesthetic
purposes. Anyway, this had some
undeniable appeals. In a slow-paced
game, any once-per-turn triggers
naturally gain a bit of extra relevance.
Also, my deck already benefited from
running a small handful of defensive
cards due to its grindy life total
race-winning commander, and these
defensive cards also help with keeping
the initiative. Also, I didn't have an
Undercity token, so I drew one on a
full-sized piece of paper and brought
miniatures to Commander games so the
people could represent their positions
on it. Who wouldn't love that?
Well, me, and that was part of my issue
with this version of the deck. A
commander deck can easily be this pretty
compact, self-contained thing, and here
I'd introduced an extra mechanic that
required me to use this full sheet of
paper prop or else buy a replacement
that's irritatingly small? It just felt
like a kind of pointless extra hassle to
need to deal with, particularly given
that my deck only ran five initiative
cards and didn't draw any of them in
some games. The other part of my issue
was that I'd cut a bunch of damaging
cards in order to make the round of
changes I'd made, and while those
damaging cards weren't great, their
absence pulled the deck even further
away from the life total pressuring
ideal I'd been striving for. I had a
functional deck that I didn't mind
playing, but the itch was still not
being scratched. So, it was time for
another change. One of my favorite cards
in the deck was Bruna, the Demagogue.
She is a three mana creature with the
text, "Whenever a player attacks one of
your opponents, if that opponent has
more life than another of your
opponents, that attacking player draws a
card and you put two plus one plus one
counters on a creature you control."
It might not immediately be clear what
that means, but basically drawing her
instantly granted the deck a whole bunch
of both value generation and damage in
the form of plus one plus one counters,
and also created a sort of political
game for my opponents. In theory, she
offered opponents card advantage, but
trading a card for two plus one plus one
counters on one of my creatures didn't
usually feel too bad, and her benefits
were much more consistent on my side of
the table. After four or five games of
drawing her and greatly enjoying what
she did to the deck, I decided to rework
the deck with her in the command zone.
In theory, this swap made sense to me.
Liesa is a damage-focused commander who
operates through the use of a life tax,
and Bruna is a damage-focused commander
who operated through the use of plus one
plus one counters. My theory about
having a hate bear oriented 99 along
with a commander who pushed a lot of
damage still absolutely intact. The
other appeal here was that hate bears
are a type of card better suited to
somewhat higher power games, and Bruna
was a more powerful commander than
Liesa, so that was an added bit of
congruence. With this new bird in the
zone, I was better equipped to handle
the sorts of higher power Commander
games that Thalia's played was itching
for. So, how was that? Well, in a lot of
ways I was correct, and the deck I ended
up producing was undoubtedly a workable
one that I could have some fun playing.
It got going fast, Bruna's plus one plus
one counters could turn my hate bears
into terrifying beaters, and the card
advantage options meant it rarely
totally ran out of steam. Even better,
with such a potent command zone, I could
afford to run more interaction than ever
before without sacrificing other things.
So, I was what was the problem?
Put simply, the nature of a Breena
command zone is dramatically different
from the nature of a Liesa command zone,
and it's different in a way that totally
destroyed the feel of the deck that I
was going for. On some level, Liesa is
an inevitability commander, an
unstoppable life total tax that always
represents a way to grind the game
toward a single digit hit point
slugfest. With her in the command zone,
the 99 could focus on keeping opponents
in check and putting in chip damage,
knowing that every chunk of health my
opponents lost was a spell they couldn't
safely cast later in the game.
By contrast, Breena is very much a tempo
commander, as I laid out in my glass
cannon commander's video last year. Like
Liesa, she helps me deal a ton of damage
to opponents, but the profile of that
damage is front loaded and reliant on
creatures sticking around on board. If I
had a smooth first several turns, I
might be swinging in with a few 7/7s or
8/8s or 9/9s on turn five. And if those
creatures stuck around, there was a
solid chance I'd be winning that game.
Problem was, if some of my creatures got
removed or if, God forbid, there was a
board wipe played that I couldn't dodge,
all of that damage momentum would slow
to a halt. In that case, I'd still have
some card advantage from Breena drawing
me an extra one to two cards per turn,
but it would take some time for me to
redevelop a board that could once again
threaten opponents. And whether I could
pull that off successfully might come
down to a variety of different factors.
To be clear, what I'm describing is a
very normal type of commander deck. If
your deck works like this, that's fine,
and I did enjoy some things about
playing it. It even makes sense as an
aggro deck. This deck came out of the
gate swinging and routinely knocked 50
points of life off of its opponents
within the first six turns of the game,
even in games it eventually lost control
of. The problem was, I wasn't just
looking for an aggro deck. I was looking
for a sort of inevitability aggro
experience, where opponents would spend
time dealing with the consequences of a
painfully low life total.
And this deck was decidedly not that.
So, how did I solve my aggro problem?
How did I create a deck that scratches
this itch of wanting opponents to spend
a lot of time looking at their life
total?
Well, step one was going back to Liesa.
Part of me was a little hesitant to do
this for purely power reasons, because
the Breena deck had been sort of bracket
four curious, and Liesa is a pretty
firmly mid power sort of commander. A
small part of me wishes she drain
opponents for three per spell, but alas,
my girl Liesa just doesn't quite have
that kind of sauce. However, this fact
also gives some opportunities, the
biggest one of which I'll get to in a
bit. To start with though, let's talk
about how I fixed some of the issues
from the previous Liesa decks. A big
piece of this was the beatdown suite. An
issue with the previous iterations of
the deck was that the 99 didn't actually
do a good job of getting life totals low
enough for Liesa to matter. In the case
of the original deck, that was a result
of running a bunch of mediocre damage
tools such as Blood Artist effects, and
in the initiative version, that was just
not really running very many damage
tools in general, unless you count
making target opponent lose five life
once every five turns. So, here,
assisted by a more lax budget than I was
using in the past, I picked out a bunch
of new damage options. Ank of Mishra,
Wound Reflection, Suture Priest, and
iconic political aggro tool Hunted
Horror. This card is so much fun, and if
you have an opponent who's receptive to
the idea of smacking Frederick over
there who's playing a gross value pile,
it's effectively 13/13 in stats for two
mana.
In terms of value, I dialed into the
small creature beats realm and grabbed
Enduring Innocence, Assemble the
Players, and Elegy Acolyte. This deck is
running more draw oriented cards than
the original, and while it's running
significantly less value generation in
total than the initiative version of the
deck, much of the draw here is quite
dense and impactful. Barrow Ghoulf was a
final inclusion here, it's just an all
around solid beat stick with a bunch of
value attached.
The biggest area I tweaked this deck
though was dead simple. I cut a lot of
hate bears. This was kind of painful
because I really like having hate bears
in my deck. It feels good to have a way
to slow opposing game plans, to build
around the restrictions of those tools
so I'm breaking parity, and to be able
to keep a high power table in check with
something like a rule of law effect. And
to be clear, I'm still running some,
some taxes, some enter tap effects, and
even Mindcensor, but the real game plan
smashers like Hushbringer and Archon of
Emeria got left behind.
One reason for this I alluded to
earlier. These cards feel most
appropriate and most needed in higher
bracket games, and Liesa isn't a
commander that really belongs at those
tables. The other reason for this choice
was that stacks in general, and rule of
law effects in particular, have this
weird clash with Liesa because they
cause opponents to cast fewer spells,
but Liesa wants opponents to be casting
more spells, or at least wants the fact
that spells cost two life to feel
relevant. It almost felt like doing her
a little dirty, as well as undermining
the goal of the deck. Like, think about
it. If I have an opponent at a lowish
life total, Liesa in play, and also a
Phyrexian Censor in play, is Liesa
reducing the number of spells my
opponent wants to play?
The answer is, who knows? They're not
running a whole ass Phyrexian deck, they
can only play one spell per turn anyway.
In a way, this is similar to some
lessons I've stumbled into with my other
decks. When I'm making a deck to
celebrate Astral Slide based value
engines, I don't want to run more
generic sources of draw that might step
on the toes of what I'm celebrating.
When I'm making a deck to bask in the
glory of having 20 lands in play, I
don't want to run a bunch of high
quality finishers that will end the game
as soon as I'm at 12 or 13.
The same goes here. This is a deck
intended to celebrate Liesa in specific
and group slug aggro in general, and
though a bit of stacks can be nice to
manage the pace of a game, it's a
powerful tool whose ability to warp the
play style of a deck needs to be
respected. Still, I find it hard to
fault my past impulses too much. Aggro
remains arguably the hardest archetype
to build in commander, particularly a
sort of grindy resilient aggro that
poses a continuing threat to any greedy
opponents. For that reason, this deck
probably isn't ever going to enter the
same sort of finished state that I'm
willing to mentally categorize some of
my other decks as being in.
That said, after focusing in harder on
what makes this deck satisfying, the
current version feels much better than
either previous iteration of Liesa.
The deck's average mana value has gone
up over time, and yet the current
version feels like it's packing more
quality two mana plays than previous
ones.
The reason why this is becomes clear
when I filter each deck by mana value in
Archidekt and then look at what's
actually there. Whereas the older
versions had a lot of kind of filler two
mana cards like Blood Artist effects and
ketchup ramp, the current version's two
drops are almost entirely value engines
and actually decent beatdown tools.
Another way I honed my intentions here
was being willing to accept a firmly
bracket three status and adapt my play
style to be more appropriate to that.
The deck still punches above its weight
class against decks that lean in on a
combo or storm sort of direction, but
it's no longer the lumbering pile of
stacks that it was before, and that lets
it feel appropriate in a much wider
range of contexts. So, broadly, this
current version of the deck feels like a
success in figuring out what I wanted
from it above all else. And the funny
thing is, I think the year with Breena
in the command zone was a really
important part of that. There are a lot
of cards out there with a powerful
iconic play style, and there's a reason
people gravitate toward them. They feel
good to draw, they feel good to play,
and you could even put one in the
command zone if you wanted to. If that
specific thing is something you want
every single game rather than just
occasionally, that might absolutely be
the right call. Even if it's not meant
to be long term, as it wasn't in this
case, playing with more extreme command
zone choices can be a great exercise in
figuring out what you do or don't enjoy
about your deck, and it's absolutely
worth a try if you have a deck you're
not happy with.
Thanks for watching. You can catch me
this weekend at LDX P Tacoma, where I'll
be along with my podcast co-hosts 3-3
Elk and the Tricket Mage. I'll be there
with my Dragon Shield Sleeve to decks,
and if you want to be enjoying the same
excellent durability and wide range of
design options, you can follow my
affiliate link down in the description
and score yourself some with a little
discount. If you want to support what I
do here in another way, you can become a
YouTube member or join my Patreon, and
you'll receive access to a back catalog
of bonus videos along with the new one
I'm putting out around the same time as
this video drops. That one will feature
me doing a deep dive into the first two
Liesa lists, and a preview for that
video will start right now.
Uh, another thing I note is the value,
and this is actually interesting because
this deck's value suite, in terms of raw
numbers, isn't that bad.
Has 12 cards in it. My current Liesa
list has 13. So, in theory, not that
wildly different, but the quality of
what's here and the density of this
value suite is very different. Some of
this is not even like draw in a sort of
conventional sense. We have like Lurrus.
Uh, Lurrus lets you cast mana value two
or less cards from your graveyard.
That's okay in this deck, but I think
it's kind of definitely weaker than some
things. I know I am running the the two
mana future sight for small creatures in
my current version. I think that feels a
lot better than Lurrus in this sort of
list, where you're just kind of running
a whole bunch of small creatures.
Probably better to be able to grab them
from the top of library than it is to be
able to grab them from graveyard in most
cases. I'm not running a whole lot of
like looping style creatures. I'm not
running that sort of thing. It's it's
kind of just a lot of guys who are
intended to stick on the board for a
little while. Sun Titan is also another
recursion option here.
Um,
six mana, I think just ended up being
kind of a lot for this effect. Like, I
want a card to do more than Sun Titan
does in this deck. And some of these
others are just like kind of generic
ones I don't really care for anymore.
Uh, Tishana's Welcome, I found that
there are just better options out there
than this. Especially, I think the the
one in Dusk Legion that turns into
uh, it starts as a creature, turns into
into an enchantment. Phyrexian Arena is
another one that I've kind of eh, it's
it's fine. I didn't feel bad about
having it. I feel probably better about
having something better.